[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMIE GREEN: Beth
Kobliner is one
of the nation's
leading authorities
on personal finance.
I measure this fact
by the fact that she's
been on "Sesame Street,"
which I find pretty--
I'm pretty starstruck now.
In addition she also
served on President Obama's
advisory council for financial
capability for young Americans.
So however you
want to measure it,
Beth knows what
she's talking about.
So please welcome Beth Kobliner.
[APPLAUSE]
BETH KOBLINER: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
JAMIE GREEN: Thanks
much for coming.
You've been on a pretty
big book tour so far.
BETH KOBLINER: I was in Detroit,
Chicago, Atlanta, Ann Arbor.
And now I'm going
for the next leg,
leaving on Thursday to
the West Coast, so a lot,
a lot going on.
It's fascinating to be meeting
parents with kids of all ages.
I look at you all as kids.
And so no, it's great.
I wanted to just say
two quick things.
Is that OK, just to start?
The first is my dad
is in the audience.
He's 87 years old,
Harold Kobliner.
[APPLAUSE]
And it's very cute,
because my dad,
he was an educator, a
principal, then chairman
of what's called the
Board of Examiners,
which was the organization that
tested teachers, principals,
and superintendents
in New York City.
And he also was a great
role model about money.
And he loves, to this day, to
go into the local supermarket
and hand out flyers about
my book to anyone he meets.
He actually singlehandedly sold
four copies in Barnes and Noble
on the Upper West
Side yesterday,
just talking to parents, oh,
my daughter wrote this book.
Simon and Schuster said we
had a real spike in sales
on the Upper West Side.
And so he hands out flyers.
And he always just gives them to
people in stores who he really
likes and who are helpful.
And in addition to giving
him like the freshest soy
milk in the back, they
also often say to him,
thank you for teaching
me these secrets.
I didn't know the
basic money issues.
And that's always been
very touching to him
and touching to me and my mom.
And I just wanted to say
that the reason I wrote
the book was basically to share
that wisdom that I grew up
with and have been writing
about for 30 years with people.
So that was the first thing.
And the second thing
is, OK, I'm old.
So I've been on "Oprah,"
and taught Elmo about money,
and met with President Obama
about children and money.
But the one thing--
now my daughter's 21.
And my son's 18.
And the little one's 13.
And the one thing they've been
impressed by, I'm like, I'm
speaking at Google today.
And they're like, no way!
Wow!
So Google, I've never been here.
It's really exciting.
And I know how
smart you all are.
JAMIE GREEN: Thank you.
And we definitely
do still, I'm sure,
have things to learn
from this book.
BETH KOBLINER: Maybe one or two.
JAMIE GREEN: I don't know.
I felt like I learned
a lot reading it.
The book works off the
premise that parents
should be teaching
their kids good money
habits from preschool all the
way through young adulthood.
And you say in the book that
a child's basic money habits
are formed by the
age of seven, which
I hope is not terrifying to
any parents of 10-year-olds
in the audience.
What sorts of things are
kids under seven picking up
on that are really
locking in those habits?
BETH KOBLINER: Well there's
some really good research
done by a woman named
Corinne Holden at University
of Wisconsin.
And I met her on
"Sesame Street."
I should say, I met her on
the street, Sesame Street.
But I did.
And she's done some remarkable
research looking at what
three-year-olds understand.
And she found they
understand exchange, when
you give money for something.
More like if you give
a card for something,
they get something back.
They see that happening.
They understand value.
A diamond ring is more
valuable than a pair of shoes,
although it depends upon what
shoes you're talking about.
And also they understand the
basic concept of needs versus
wants.
So if you go shopping
in a supermarket
with a young child you
can say, you know what?
We really need milk.
But we really want
chocolate milk.
Or we really need vegetables.
But we really want potato chips.
And we're going to spend most
of our money on things we need.
And you can play the
game, need-want game.
And as a kid gets
older, how do we
find the less expensive brand?
And what are the trade-offs,
and all those sort of things
you could do in a supermarket.
But I think it's key that
talking to kids at very
young ages, as little
as three, really
has an impact on having them
understand these concepts more
and more, which is really--
I was surprised by that.
I didn't really realize that.
And then the scary one
was Cambridge University
did a study.
And they said by age seven,
many of those behaviors
that we associate with
money habits are actually
set by age seven.
So I think they're
talking more about
like delayed gratification
and executive function.
But it's not that
it's absolutely set.
There's a lot more to teach
an eight-year-old up, I think.
And that comes from
everyday moments,
whether it's talking
to your kid about,
OK, I'm going to go buy a car.
That's my editor.
He got my book.
And he's like, I never
would have thought of that.
But I brought my 10-year-old
to the car dealership,
because I would
think, she'd be bored.
But I brought her.
And I started telling her, OK,
well I'm going to buy a car.
This is what the price is.
I'm going to try to negotiate.
I'm going to get
an interest rate.
Maybe I'll go to a bank
for the interest rate.
And those conversations
and those experiences,
frankly, are pretty
meaningful for kids.
With everything
digital and online,
I think it's really essential
that parents start doing that
at many ages as kids get older.
JAMIE GREEN: To
a certain extent,
that sounds like an
extension of good parenting--
BETH KOBLINER:
Right, oh absolutely.
JAMIE GREEN:
--explain to your kid
why you're doing
what you're doing.
Let them into those decision.
Make sure that things that
would otherwise go unspoken
are explained and clarified.
What happens to a kid whose
parents don't consciously
make an effort to teach them
about money and finance?
BETH KOBLINER: What we're
seeing is-- so two years ago,
the government participated
in this international test
for 15-year-olds.
And it's called
PISA is the test.
And what was ironic, I was
on the President's council
at the time.
And we couldn't come
up with the $200,000
to participate in this test,
which OK, as a government.
But we did.
And we were able
to take this test.
And we found that 15-year-olds
in the United States
are mediocre, right
in the middle.
So there are countries,
many, many countries
from all over that are
doing so much better than we
are in teaching kids basics.
We're talking basics,
understanding the interest rate
on a credit card, or even being
able to dissect a paycheck,
not understanding where that
money's going, whether it's
Social Security or tax.
So I have in my book
a chart on all that.
But it's so clear that
our nation, by not
under-- someone
I work with said,
financial rights
are civil rights.
And if you understand
that it's a mistake
to get into credit card debt
that's charging you 18%,
or if you understand that
if you miss a student loan
payment, that will likely
go on your credit record
for seven years,
those kind of things,
I've had so many people
tell me, I didn't know.
And I want my kids to
know and to understand
this in age appropriate ways.
JAMIE GREEN: It's
interesting where
you say, you just said that
one way of looking at it
is that financial issues
are civil rights issues,
because you mentioned
a statistic in the book
that nearly half
of all Americans
couldn't pull together
$2,000 for an emergency.
And this isn't just
half of all Americans
don't have $2,000 in the bank.
But they wouldn't
be able to borrow it
from friends and family.
They could not get $2,000.
BETH KOBLINER: They
couldn't even get it--
you think, well use
your credit card.
They didn't have access
to credit to get $2,000.
So it probably means that they--
we don't know exactly--
but it probably means that
they are in credit trouble.
And they no longer
had a line of credit.
So when you think of that,
that's pretty terrifying.
I've heard it called
financial fragility.
We're so unsecure.
We're not financially secure.
And I think that is
so important, just
the concept of saving up money.
And the more I've been touring,
I really strongly believe-- oh,
and you're Google.
You can help me
make this happen.
I think cash should come back.
I really think that.
I'm not getting any nods.
You're like, nah.
But when I was a kid, my parents
would sit at the kitchen table.
My mom and dad would
pay the bills together.
And there were a pile of bills.
And they'd write a check.
And they'd balance
their checkbook.
How many people here balance
a checkbook honestly?
One person.
So interesting.
My dad could stand up
and tell you how many,
over 87 years, how many times he
found errors in the bank math.
And I know you're all making a
decision of time versus money.
And my time is worth
more than checking
to find the $10 mistake.
But sometimes
there are mistakes.
And I think for kids, my
favorite story in the book
is a mom going to
Target with her son.
And he was about eight or nine.
And she was buying juice boxes.
And she pulled out a $20.
And her kid said mommy,
don't pay for it.
Use the card.
That's the way to-- you get it
for free if you use the card.
And I think that mindset,
particularly for younger kids,
and of course now
Venmo and all the ways
people are exchanging money
without exchanging money.
And we know that MIT
did a study years
ago showing that people spend
twice as much if you use
a card than if you use cash.
And I think the pain
of paying is something.
When you fork over dollars,
it feels like oh, I'm
really giving up something.
That's a behavioral
economics finding.
So I think the inability to
make a connection between buying
things, and I'm going into
a bank and getting money,
instead of it all being online.
I think that that is something
that children are missing out
on.
And a great parent would
say hey, come on over.
I'm paying the bills online.
But it doesn't really
look any different
to a four-year-old or
five-year-old than someone
doing work, because it's
hard to make that connection
versus the concrete experience.
JAMIE GREEN: So you, in
the book you advocate for--
you advocate against giving
middle schoolers and teenagers
prepaid debit cards.
Have them work on cash.
But it sounds also like
adults would benefit
from working in cash too.
BETH KOBLINER: I think,
or at least modeling it
for your child.
That's how I learned
to make change.
I had about four
jobs in high school.
And one of them was
working at the local diner.
I'm from Queens originally.
And that was one
of my first jobs.
And I was an AP math.
But that wasn't my top subject.
We both bonded.
We went to Brown, English major.
But when I was making change,
I remember that somebody
would be like $3.84 bill.
And they'd give me a $10.
So I'd try to subtract
it in my head.
And my dad's like,
no, you just count up.
If it's $0.34, a
penny for $0.35,
then counting up
all the way to $10.
And I learned that with cash.
And I think just the counting,
little kids not knowing
coins or dollar bills, I
think that's all part of it.
And I think that
is all important.
Not that we will get
rid of our credit cards.
They're super convenient.
But if you're, of course,
using a credit card
and you're paying it off in
full, it's good to do that.
It's good to have
a credit record.
But I think that that's
been pushed way too early.
And I think kids
are missing out.
JAMIE GREEN: So
we've already touched
on a couple of specific
bits of advice.
A big one that
comes up in the book
that I thought was really
interesting, because it's
one that is so distant in
my memory, is allowances.
So what is your take on
giving kids an allowance?
What are the learning
opportunities there?
What do you think about that?
BETH KOBLINER: So this study
at University of Minnesota--
and I have to say, this one
wasn't a randomized controlled
study.
But it was interesting in
that they followed children
who were given chores
when they were little,
whether it's making
the bed or whatever
they were doing regularly.
And they found that having
chores, not tied to money
but just chores as part
of a family, that's
your responsibility.
We're team.
We're all in it together.
That was one predictor
of a child's success
in terms of certain
milestones like graduating
from high school or graduating
from school in general
or starting a career, that
that experience of doing
a job as part of a family was
quite important to a child's
development.
But when you put money
into the equation,
and you give kids
money for chores,
it takes away from that
intrinsic value of,
I'm going to work
hard for my family.
We're in this together.
And it dilutes it.
Same with Roland
Fryer, great guy.
He did research on giving
kids money for grades.
How many people got
money for grades?
Most of you not, because your
parents said, you work hard.
Whether you were born with it
or you were instilled with it,
this desire to work hard
for working hard's sake.
And maybe we all knew, one
day I'll get to Google.
And you did.
But I think that idea of
parents instilling that in kids,
so that's--
it doesn't work.
Roland Fryer, in a wonderfully
randomized controlled study,
showed that giving
kids money and saying,
I'll give you $100
if you get an A,
or $50 if you get
an A doesn't work.
JAMIE GREEN: Is it the same
for a gift or another kind
of reward?
BETH KOBLINER: If you reward
afterwards, that's different.
If the kid does really
well, and you just
want to take them
out for ice cream,
that's a different thing.
But if it's given
as an incentive,
any kind of gift or
reward doesn't work.
So the question of
allowance, so given that, you
want to give allowance.
You can give allowance.
And I looked into two
dozen studies on allowance.
They were international studies.
And one from Canada found that
when people give their children
allowance, the kids end
up being a little more
responsible with money.
And they save a little more.
The study from
England found when
parents give their
kids allowance,
the kids are feeling
more entitled.
So there was no one right
answer with the allowance.
But what I have
found overall is you
want to be clear to your child
and in your own mind what
this allowance is for.
So if it's a really little
kid, like a 10-year-old,
it's good to say OK,
this is going to be--
you have six LEGO kits.
If you want another one,
and it's not your birthday,
and it's not the holidays,
and grandma and grandpa aren't
getting it, you have
to save up for that.
And you figure out what
that would roughly cost,
because I think one
mistake parents can
make is I think back.
When I was a kid, I
got $1 for babysitting.
And now people get $20
an hour for babysitting.
So thinking of what
it really costs,
and then having
kids make choices.
And you can buy the
Doritos on your way home.
And you learn opportunity cost.
Or you could put that $1 into
a jar, a piggy bank or whatever
and save it up.
And then kids see
that excitement
of building up that money.
So I think allowance
works like that.
You can also give just a
regular allowance once a week.
The rules of them are
give a kid's age--
10-year-old gets $10 a week.
But when I'm talking
about this in the Midwest,
the moms are like, I would
like $520 handed to me a year.
So it really just depends.
I think as a parent, we
really got most serious
about this when our kids were
going to college and said,
OK, how do we come up
with a realistic amount?
They were lucky.
They don't have to
take out student loans.
And they were in
a situation where
we'll pay for their
health care and books.
But if we wanted
to get-- they work.
They both work.
But if we give them
a little bit of cash
for that semester,
how much should it be?
And what would it
be expected for?
So of course, I'm like,
I'll just give them $100.
And then we thinking about it.
And we're like, no.
This is money for if they want
to go on a trip with a friend,
or they want to go--
so my daughter, for
example, went skiing,
even though she doesn't ski.
Kids these days.
She went over winter break.
A bunch of friends
were going to Canada.
And they were driving up.
But she had to go later.
So we saw her sitting
there, looking
at the train versus the plane.
And the train took nine hours.
And the plane took two hours.
And she made the choice
to take the train.
And of course I'm thinking,
[GROANS] maybe just
let her take the plane.
It's so long.
And then my husband and
I were talking about it.
No this is-- to each
other, we didn't
do this in front of
her-- but the idea
that this is what we agreed to.
And this is so good for her
to be making those choices.
And she had fun on the train.
She said, I looked
out the window.
And I did my homework.
And I read a lot.
I read a novel.
I think at every level,
when you're a parent,
the hardest part is
coming up with something
and then sticking with it.
JAMIE GREEN: Yeah,
that consistency.
There ends up being a
big shift though around--
I don't know if it
happens in middle school--
babysitting jobs,
or in high school
once, I remember just
like waiting and waiting
to be 16 so I could get a job.
I was so excited.
But it seems like from
the research you found,
there is a mix of
some benefits but also
some possible sacrifices
with high school jobs,
especially during
the school year.
BETH KOBLINER: Exactly.
There are a lot of great
books in the last few years
have come out that talked about
kids are coddled too much.
And they should be out
working in high school
like we used to do.
And that I agree with for sure
in theory and in practice.
However the Department of Labor
Statistics did an analysis.
And they found that
if a child is working
12 hours, 13 hours
a week, then it
doesn't have a negative
impact on their grades.
In fact it may give them
a teeny boost in grades.
And it could be because they're
using their time efficiently.
But once you get to that
15 hour or over mark,
it has an impact on grades.
So we know that when kids
do less homework in math,
it's a direct correlation
to their math grades.
And then of course,
when we're talking
about thinking about college
and not just how great a school
you get into, but also which
will give you the most aid
and opening up your
opportunities to get more aid,
I think it's a hard trade-off.
And of course, there
are many, many,
many families that
need their child
to work to contribute
to the family.
But I think it's important
just to know that number.
Whereas in college,
interestingly,
you can work up to 20 hours.
Kids who work up to 20 hours
but work in an on-campus job
have slightly higher GPAs than
kids that don't work at all.
JAMIE GREEN: And
then there's also
the question of is that
work important preparation
for future careers
and things like that?
And so you, in the
book, I think you
advocate for college
students working
during the summer, maybe as
a trade-off for working less
during the school year.
BETH KOBLINER:
Absolutely, I think
working in the summer for
high school and college.
And then that job during
high school, for example,
if it's during the
summer, it's a great way
to then segue, with
your kids, to the magic
of compound interest,
which is a hard one
to talk to a 14-year-old about.
This is great,
compound interest.
And the idea is if
a child is, say, 14.
And they work every summer.
And maybe they earn
$1,000 that summer.
And they work for
four summers in a row.
And if they put that
money into a Roth IRA--
and in order to open a Roth
IRA, you need to have income.
So it has to be from the job.
So you put that $1,000 in
each year for four years.
And then you stop and
never put money in again.
You would most
likely, if you put it
in an index fund or an ETF--
and I talk about
those in my book--
you would be likely
to have over $100,000.
So saying that to a kid, you
do it for these four years.
That's how much
you're going to have.
That's fairly compelling,
I think, for many kids.
And also it helps if you're
applying for financial aid,
because colleges expect
you to contribute
much more of a kid's savings
than a parent's savings.
But if it's in an
IRA, they don't
look at that money typically,
which is a good thing to know.
JAMIE GREEN: There's
so many trade-offs.
No, no, no, it's all really
clear in the book though.
There are a lot of little
worksheets and tables
that I found really,
really helpful.
BETH KOBLINER: Thank you.
JAMIE GREEN: We were saying,
the book starts or includes
in every chapter
ways to introduce
these ideas to a preschooler,
whether it's just
playing with coins or talking
about wants and needs.
But you also take
all of the advice
passed college into
young adulthood.
And so how much input on a 23,
24-year-old/s financial life do
you think a parent
should be having?
BETH KOBLINER: I think
a lot of guidance
is needed, either because they
didn't talk about it before,
or kids are graduating.
If you don't mind me
asking one more question,
how many people here
have student loans
that they're still paying off?
[LAUGHS] The Brown major.
JAMIE GREEN: You're talking
about grad school too.
BETH KOBLINER: Yeah, grad
school, including grad school?
No, you all paid it off.
But I think that many,
many people graduate
from college with
lots of student debt.
And if it's federal
student debt,
there are a lot of
wonderful repayment options.
And I met someone
here who worked
at one of these companies
that will also refinance
private student loans, typically
if you're from a school that
makes the list of
schools that they
think those kids
have a likelihood
to pay off their debt too.
It's interesting.
But I think that talking
about repayment options,
moving back home is something
that-- it's so interesting.
One part of the country,
I said, out of college,
you have to move back home.
And they're like, oh.
And then another
part of the country,
I actually spoke
to these kids, it's
called College Advising Corps.
And these are kids who
graduate from high school.
And it's like a Peace Corps
but for working in lower income
high schools that don't
have college counselors.
And these kids
volunteer for two years.
And they learn as
much as they possibly
can about being a
college counselor
and helping kids
with financial aid.
And when I said, well,
move back home, kids said,
I'm from the Bronx.
And I have four siblings.
And we live in a
one room apartment.
I can't move back home.
I'm like, OK, so the
perspective there can be.
But I do think there's so much
we can do to educate people.
I have one quick
story about my dad.
And a lot of the book is
about delayed gratification.
And the marshmallow
experiments that--
Walter Michel is a professor.
He was at Stanford.
Now he's at Columbia.
And he did an experiment
with five-year-olds.
And he put a marshmallow
in front of them.
And then he said, look, you
can eat this marshmallow now.
Feel free.
But if you wait, I'm going to
bring you a second marshmallow.
And they did this
when kids are five.
And then he tracked these kids
for years and years and years.
And now those kids
are in their 50s.
But when he did that experiment,
he'd walked out of the room.
The examiner would
walk out of the room.
And some kids
would be like, they
eat the marshmallow right away.
But some kids would wait.
And they'd wait.
And they wait.
And they would usually whistle
or try to distract themselves.
And then they would wait for
him for 15 minutes to come back.
And they got that marshmallow,
that second marshmallow.
And they found that
those kids who waited
had on average 200 points
higher on their SATs.
I feel like I should
start a prep course, a SAT
course with that in mind.
I don't know how.
Someone here can help
me figure it out.
200 points higher
on their SATs, they
reported having happier
lives, better relationships
and lower body mass indexes.
So that ability to delay
gratification is incredible.
JAMIE GREEN: Is the
idea that it's intrinsic
or that it's learned very early?
BETH KOBLINER: Great question.
JAMIE GREEN: I say this
as a marshmallow loving
five-year-old who's concerned.
BETH KOBLINER: Well
that's the great question.
So what we know is it wasn't
that these kids had this higher
moral code.
Or they were even, oh,
I could deny myself.
It was more of an executive
function, the ability to,
I'm going to pretend that's
not really a marshmallow.
I'm going to pretend there's
a picture of marshmallow.
Or I'm going to pretend
there's dirt on it.
And I don't want it anymore.
Or I'm going to pretend
I'm a superhero.
And I'm strong, all
these different ways.
And now what the
research is looking
at is how do we teach that?
Can we teach it?
And I was brought
up in an environment
where my dad was a teacher,
at this time in 1969.
And he came home and told
my mom, OK, New York City
introduced a new pension plan.
And we're going to put
away 50% of our income
in this pension plan.
So we lived in Queens,
tiny little house.
My dad earned like
$30,000 at the time.
They had three kids,
a mortgage, a car.
And my mom, Shirley,
said Harold, what?
How can we save
half of our income?
We have three kids and a home.
We can't afford it.
And my father said, we
can't afford not to.
And that set the theme, I think,
of how he approached life.
And he was born in poverty.
He had no money.
And when he was a child,
in order to keep going,
there's a story about him
where he was eight years old.
And he felt like he
wanted to make some money.
So he sat in the candy store
right near the tenement
where he grew up.
And in those days, people
didn't have telephones.
So my dad would sit.
The phone would ring
in the candy store.
And he'd get up and say,
call for Mrs. Jones.
Mrs. Jones?
Phone call.
He'd go out.
And Mrs. Jones would
come down the stairs
and give him a nickel or a dime.
He'd get a tip.
And he was in a candy store.
So he always used
to say to my kids,
do you think, what
did I do with it?
My kids are like, you
bought candy, all the candy.
And he said, no.
I saved it and gave
it to my parents.
And because he knew the
delayed gratification
there was that his parents
wouldn't fight as much.
And they'd have
bread on the table.
I hesitate sometimes
to tell that story,
because not everyone's Harold.
That is extraordinary
to be eight years old
and not eat the candy.
But I think that kind
of thinking for kids,
and even telling those
stories, kids love anecdotes.
You tell them this story.
They're like, I
could be like Harold.
Maybe I'll make a
little Harold doll.
JAMIE GREEN: We're
going to open it up
to questions in a
couple of minutes.
So if you have questions,
you can line up
at the two microphones
in the aisles.
But I wanted to ask you
about something else.
Because you actually,
in the book,
in general I often think
of good parenting advice
as being based on openness
and communication.
But there are some things
about parents' finances
that you advocate
keeping private, which
I found especially interesting,
because my parents are
divorced, which I think
brings money talk out
into the open in a
very different way.
And there were, in
terms of child support
and who could afford what,
and it can be fraught.
But you hear a lot
more from your parents,
maybe because they're just
talking through you instead of
to each other.
So what are some of the things
that, at different ages,
you think parents shouldn't
talk to their kids about?
BETH KOBLINER: I think that when
children are five, six, seven,
eight, nine, you don't have to--
telling them what
your salary is, to me,
is just out of context.
They don't have
anywhere to put it.
So if you're like, I
make $100,000 a year.
Well then why can't
I get that candy bar?
And you could explain it.
But I think the numbers
are meaningless to very
young children.
I think as kids get older,
I've been having a lot
of questions from parents.
My 16-year-old wants to
know how much I make.
And should I tell her or not?
And in those cases, I think,
particularly if they're--
you start thinking.
And this one mom, we
were talking about it.
And she realized,
because her daughter
was nervous about college.
Would she be able to afford it?
Would she be able to?
Should she try to get
into the best school?
Or would she just
not be able to go?
So those kind of,
I think those--
but I think you don't
have to tell your--
the ideal is not to fight in
front of your kids about money.
They actually said that when
parents fight a lot in front
of their kids about
money, those kids
are three times more
likely to have $500 or more
in credit card debt in college.
I think that trying to--
you don't talk to
your kids about it.
It's just got to
be age appropriate.
My 401(k) went down.
They don't care.
I'm frightened about
paying for college.
There's anxiety that
can be passed along
to kids that, I don't
think it's a healthy thing.
JAMIE GREEN: The balance between
being conscientious and being
anxious, kids pick
up on that worry.
And on that
wonderful happy note,
let's take it to the
audience, who can maybe
turn those things around.
You want to go first?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
So first of all, I want to
say thank you for being here.
Some number of years ago--
I won't say how many--
I managed to get a copy
of "Get I Financial Life."
And it helped me tremendously.
So thank you.
I've been flipping through
the book for the first time
just now.
And I think one of the things--
we can acknowledge that
Google pays ridiculously well.
Nobody here deserves to
make nearly as much money
as they do.
So I think a lot of
Googlers are in a fairly--
BETH KOBLINER: There'll
be a hat in the back.
AUDIENCE: So I see
things in your book about
don't worry about keeping
up with the Kardashians.
Don't buy your kid a car.
I think, just my own
experience, those
weren't options growing up.
And as a parent, my
kids are 10 and 12.
We're at this point where like,
gosh, a lot of your friends
have all this stuff.
And it's certainly, it's a want.
But it's certainly within the
range of affordability for us.
And figuring out that
line between am I
denying you and making you
an outcast socially, things
that you could be doing?
Every high school kid
in my town has a car.
And the idea of
not doing-- so I'm
curious on how you make
a trade-off, if you have
any information on teaching
kids the hard lessons
versus making them an
outcast, that sort of thing.
BETH KOBLINER: I
love that question.
And I've heard it in
different communities.
And I think that a lot of
people who grew up middle class
or really struggling, and
then you're at Google.
Or you are making
a lot of money.
Or you have a lot of money.
It's very difficult.
Personally I'm all about denial
to my children, not completely.
But my daughter was the last
one to get her cell phone.
And I think that it
was so ingrained in me,
these values in my head.
And also I'm writing
about this, to be fair.
But I think that by the
time, if I think delaying,
first of all, just as a mom I'm
saying this, in much technology
is so much better, because
kids are still reading books.
And they're still communicating
and talking and looking you
in the eye.
And I think that my classic
story was when my daughter--
who's now 21--
when she was 13, she said,
I'm going with some friends.
We live in Manhattan.
We're going to go.
Can we go to Macy's?
And we were a little
overprotective.
She was our first child.
And we're like, OK, you can go.
And she's like,
and all my friends
have a credit card, their
parents' credit card.
Or one was a debit card.
And the parents, they
were good parents.
They gave them a limit.
But I said, absolutely not.
I said, I'm going
to give you cash.
And she's like, all right.
She was a little embarrassed.
But she went.
And she used cash.
And she said, you know what?
You gave me $100 mom.
And it was $103.
So I had to put something back.
Whereas if you hand your kid
a card, a prepaid card even,
you can put it
exactly to the limit.
But often it's like
off of your account.
And if your kid comes
back and spends $120,
you're like, good job.
You didn't spend $4,000.
And I think that, the
cash, and talking about it
with kids, because it's
trickier with everything now,
with Venmo.
And I just felt,
up through college,
they did not need to have
experiences with plastic.
And I think parents also,
one interesting thing
I've been hearing is that
we're worried about our kids
not having a credit
report or a credit record.
And that, to me, feels
very insidious in that
the notion of needing--
you will get a credit card
when you graduate from college.
There will not be a problem
getting a credit card.
And I think just
because now it's
Credit Karma, which I like.
You get it for free,
your credit score.
But I think that people
are rushing it too much.
So in terms, I think
if you talk and say,
I know you're the last one
in your grade to get a phone.
And that's just the way we feel.
And we understand
it could be hard.
I understand.
And yeah, those people--
I always hear often, those
people have a summer house.
Or those people have,
and it's like, we
have such a good family.
We're so lucky.
And everybody makes
different choices.
And this is the choice we make.
And we love you just as much.
It sounds so trite.
You don't have to say yes.
He's like, yeah,
it's really trite.
But that idea of those
kind of conversations
and again, I was lucky.
My family, we had
those conversations.
And we still, my
husband and I, still
have those conversations with
our kids and just explaining.
And I have to say when
I see the next phase,
and I've been interviewing
lots of kids, 21, 22
and talking about it.
And some of you are
probably close to that age.
And the whole I'm not really--
your generation, by the way,
the millennial generation,
has much less credit card debt
than Gen-Xer's in their 20s
or baby boomers in their 20s.
And that's probably because
in 2009, President Obama
passed the Card
Act, which said you
have to be 21 to get a
credit card in college
unless a parent cosigns.
Never do that.
Never cosign a credit
card with your kid.
I've met so many
parents who said,
yeah, ruined my credit rating.
My kid used my card.
So never do that.
And also just I would say wait
till junior year in college
before.
Or suggest to them,
OK, if you have a job,
you can get a credit card.
Pay it off immediately.
But personally I've
seen freshman year,
they have to do laundry
for the first time.
Not all kids, but my kids,
they had to do laundry.
And there's a lot
going on freshman year.
They're studying hard.
And they're trying
to figure it all out.
And I think adding
credit to the mix, when
I graduated in 1986
from college, everyone
I knew had lots of
credit card debt,
because it was handed out.
Someone's like, I
went to a frat party.
I got a credit card.
It was just handed out.
So I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
BETH KOBLINER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I've been
trying to figure out
how to ask this question.
I think the marshmallow
example is probably
the best way to do it.
There's probably
not hard data on it.
But I was just wondering
if you had an opinion,
based on your knowledge.
What's too early?
It's very tempting
for my kid, who
is very responsive to all
kinds of different things
we throw at him.
It's very tempting to
say, OK, you know what?
You're two.
Here's a marshmallow.
And let's see you fail.
And then we'll try
again in a few months.
Maybe that's a little damaging.
And I'm wondering if you
have a thought on that.
BETH KOBLINER: That's
another great real question.
So when I was reading about
the marshmallow experiment,
and I looked at his
original papers.
And then I went online.
And they're all these parents,
here's the marshmallow.
But don't eat it!
And these kids are like,
oh my goodness, why?
I want it.
And I wrote in
the book, you just
want to go buy a
bag of marshmallows
and go under the covers
then eat them yourself.
So I think that it's
a great question.
I'm happy and I pride myself on
my book being research based.
But I think when you're
looking at being a parent,
sometimes it's better not to
have the research in your head.
And I think certainly
my dad didn't have any
of that research in his head.
And it's sort of like, I think
with that knowledge sometimes
can come anxiety.
Where does my kid
fall on the scale?
And I got to tell you.
This is something my mom
would say all the time.
There are always bumps
in the roads with kids.
And they'll be,
they're so great.
The teacher said they're
not paying attention,
because they're
writing, math code
under the desk in second
grade, whatever it is.
I made that up.
My child is not writing
math code in second grade.
But I think that
I strongly believe
it's good to know this stuff and
to think about it a little bit.
And it's fun when it crops up.
But I would not be testing
kids, because they'll
start getting a little
anxious probably, or feeling
that I'm being tested.
So I would say it's
just the parenting,
the daily life of parenting.
Wow, look at that house.
That's a beautiful house.
One day, maybe if we
save up a lot of money,
maybe we'll get that house.
Or yeah, we saved a lot.
So we're going on a vacation.
I'm so excited, just making it
a part of everyday conversation
in life.
And it does take more
effort for your generation
to do that because
again you're not saying,
let's take a trip to the bank.
Or opening a bank account
is a great thing to do.
But the interest rate is 0.1%.
But that's almost
besides the point,
in terms of just having that
experience of going to a bank.
Some banks still have
passbook savings accounts.
And of course, make sure
they don't have fees.
Because your kid
will put in $10.
Then it's gone the next month.
But does that help a little?
AUDIENCE: Hello, so my wife
and I have a disagreement.
I've started paying my
eight-year-old for each time
he practices the piano.
I give him a dime
each time he does it.
And if he does it for a
whole week, I give him $1.
She thinks it takes some of the
joy out of playing the piano,
because he's doing
it for money now.
BETH KOBLINER: Perhaps
it enhances the joy.
AUDIENCE: I think so.
So what do you think
about paying kids
for chores in general?
BETH KOBLINER:
Again, the research,
when you look at the
idea of doing chores--
now that's different,
because piano--
so when you're
talking about chores,
I think it's not a good idea
to tie regular family chores.
Everybody has to have a job.
I used to load the dishwasher,
empty the dishwasher,
make my bed.
Whatever it is, that's
something I had to do.
If you're talking about one off
things, like OK, could you--
I don't know-- I haven't lived
in a house in a long time.
What do you do?
Get the leaves out
of the whatever?
JAMIE GREEN: Clean a garage?
BETH KOBLINER: Clean the garage.
JAMIE GREEN: An
interesting distinction
you make in the book is
that you can pay children
for chores that if
they weren't doing it,
you might hire someone to do.
But the regular
maintenance stuff--
BETH KOBLINER: The
regular maintenance.
So where does piano
fit into that?
I feel like--
JAMIE GREEN: Is that
like paying for studying?
BETH KOBLINER: I think it's a
little like paying for grades,
which again Roland
Fryer's randomized
controlled study showed
on average, it just
doesn't matter.
It doesn't help.
Now he also found, which is if
you're talking about small one
off projects, so maybe it would
fit into just complete it.
If you complete
it five times, I'm
going to reward you at
the end of the week.
He was saying that that can help
a child achieve a small term
goal.
But at the end of the day--
and it's funny.
My husband and I have this
one, because when I was a kid,
I took piano lessons.
Eight years, and now
I can't play a thing.
He was more improvisational and
played when he felt like it.
And two of our three kids
ended up being like that.
And I was nervous.
Why aren't they
taking piano lessons?
So I think that I
would, in your case,
probably side with your wife.
Sorry.
We could call her on the phone.
Guess what?
But in the sense that in
the end, the point of it is
they're loving playing piano.
And I think that no matter
what value you give to it,
you want the value
for your child
to eventually come from them.
And I pretty strongly feel
that in my control group
of three, of then my
brother and me, when
it was demanded or paid for--
we weren't paid for it--
probably if your child
was being paid for it,
maybe there's
something else they
would pick that they
really want to do that they
would spend the time doing.
So it's a tricky one.
But I would side with not
paying for playing the piano.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BETH KOBLINER: Sorry.
But you don't have
to tell your wife.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMIE GREEN: It never happened.
BETH KOBLINER: My
dad has a question.
You can grab the microphone
for him if you want.
HAROLD KOBLINER: I'd like
to tell you first of all,
I've been retired 26 years.
And I was on a cruise
a few years ago.
And a guy was
sitting next to me.
And he said, what do you do?
So I said, well I'm an
educator in schools and so on.
Says, how long you been retired?
Well at that point, I
said about 23 years.
So he looked at me and he
said, how do you survive?
Now the problem, I think, that
the country is heading into
is the problem of people
are living longer.
And by living longer,
you're going to have--
need finances over a
longer period of time.
And if you don't
have it, it's going
to cause major problems,
whether it's Social Security,
you don't have enough.
But it will aggravate
the situation.
And I think we have to address
that that your children should
be educated enough to save.
My wife, we were
married 65 years.
And my wife and I went on
our first trip, major trip
to Europe celebrating
our 25th anniversary.
But we were constantly,
when she said--
my wife, and I said, we're
going to take that tax
deferred annuity.
And now we must do it.
But I also got two
jobs to supplement it.
I ran a college entrance
coaching course.
Remember Stanley Kaplan?
BETH KOBLINER: He
was his competitor.
Stanley won.
HAROLD KOBLINER:
He did very well.
But he was a teacher in New York
City school system, by the way.
He was teacher of economics.
And Chuck Schumer the
Senate minority leader
for the Democrats was a
kid in James Madison High
School in Brooklyn.
And he offered to give the
kids free coaching course,
if they do his
mimeographing work,
duplicating his knowledge.
And that's how he started,
by the way, Stanley Kaplan.
He was teacher of economics.
But anyway getting
back to this, it's
crucial for our
country's future to plan
helping our children become
independent and not dependent.
I've had no problems
being retired 26 years.
BETH KOBLINER: Just
because you behaved.
HAROLD KOBLINER:
And it's something
that you have to plan for.
BETH KOBLINER: And I
didn't get that Lacoste
shirt I always wanted.
I opened one chapter in that.
I wanted an alligator shirt.
Then my aunt gave us a bag
of clothes from our wealthier
cousins.
And there was an alligator.
So I cut it off and
sewed it on my sweater.
And of course, this
mean girl said,
that's not a real
alligator sweater.
You sewed that on.
And I was like, oh.
But those things you remember.
but we had such a
great childhood.
It's interesting how that
kind of philosophy is just,
I think, the heart of it.
JAMIE GREEN: Thank you so much.
BETH KOBLINER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE GREEN: Oh,
gosh, I'm sorry.
One last quick question.
AUDIENCE: So I'm not sure if it
falls under financial education
or more child psychology.
But going back to getting
paid for piano lessons,
for practicing the piano, I want
to ask the other way around.
Let's say my kid does something
I really don't like her doing.
And I'm willing to pay
her for not doing it.
[LAUGHTER]
How would that be done?
Should it be done?
BETH KOBLINER: I would also
say that shouldn't be done,
because they have to learn.
Again, I'm not a psychologist.
So take it with a
grain of salt. But I
think, in terms
of the stuff I've
read, that it's the same thing.
You don't want to say
a child knows, well
if I misbehave--
first of all, you're
giving them a perverse
incentive that OK, I misbehave,
then I get money to stop it.
So first I'm going to misbehave.
Then I'll get paid
to stop doing it.
Does that makes sense?
But also that it should
come from within.
I'm not going to misbehave,
because it really bugs my dad.
And I don't want to bug my
dad, because he's a nice dad.
Or I want to--
I think of those
again, you're giving
an external, extrinsic
reward or disincentive, money
or whatever to do,
to change a behavior,
I think, is not a good
thing for children,
because children have to
understand intrinsically
why it's good to be good or to
listen or to stop being bad.
And I think it confuses it.
Thanks.
JAMIE GREEN: Thank you.
And that's all the
time we have for today.
Thank you so much, Beth.
BETH KOBLINER: Thank you.
Thank you so much.